[Musique]
bonsoir à tous dimanche à la fin de
cette semaine nous votons pour les
élections municipales la dernière ligne
droite donc france 3 continue de
bouleverser ses programmes chaque soir à
18 heures nous vous proposons un débat
avec les candidats des principales
villes encore en jeu en franche comté
demain ce sera à belfort mercredi lons
le saunier jeudi besançon et ce soir
pour lancer la semaine donc
héricourt ils sont trois à briguer la
mairie de la deuxième ville la plus
peuplée du département de haute saône
fernand burkhalter maire sortant vous
êtes aussi conseiller départemental pour
ces municipales vous mener une liste
divers gauche vous avez 66 en face avoue
gilles lazar 64 ans médecin généraliste
vous êtes élu municipal sortant
d'opposition et vous êtes communiste à
vos côtés patrick adam 50 ans médecin
psychiatre vous êtes déjà présenter à
des élections sous l'étiquette debout la
france vous avez été exclu du parti de
nicolas dupont aignan vous êtes
aujourd'hui membre du parti les
républicains vous menez une liste divers
droite pour ces municipales bonjour à
tous les trois merci d'avoir accepté
notre invitation alors le 15 mars
dernier c'est vous fernand burkhalter
qui avait basculé en tête au premier
tour avec presque 47 % des suffrages
un peu plus de 13 points et 400 voix
d'avancé sur gilles lazar
patrick adam vous arriviez en troisième
position les listes de catherine dormoy
et d'isabelle à pro n'ont pas réalisé un
score suffisant pour se maintenir au
second tour
alors le tirage au sort vous a désigné
vous fernand burkhalter pour débuter ce
débat pouvez vous nous dire pourquoi
vous êtes candidat à un nouveau mandat
tout d'abord bonjour bonjour aux deux
autres candidats et puis je voudrais
saluer le travail de la majorité
sortante qui a été extrêmement positif
pour la ville et pour le pays
d'héricourt et qui marque une évolution
très positive de notre ville et de
nombreuses réalisations
patrick adam pourquoi êtes vous candidat
à cette mairie d'héricourt je suis
candidat à cette mairie d'héricourt
parce que je me montre ambitieux pour
cette ville
je souhaite la redynamiser en assurant
un développement économique et urbain
harmonieux
soucieux de l'humain et respectant la
nature faire ce qu en sorte que cette
ville qui est la deuxième ville de haute
saône dispose des infrastructures
optimales et comme je l'avais nommé
réveiller la belle endormie de l'airé
urbaine en alliant audace et protection
parce que je suis je me définis comme un
gaulliste social et mes valeurs
cardinales somme la valeur travail la
protection des plus faibles et la
liberté d'entreprendre
merci patrick adam pourquoi êtes vous
candidat bonjour comme le jour gilles
lazar excusez-moi hop comme vous l'avez
dit comme je suis médecin généraliste
est récurent depuis 1983
j'ai été adjoint chargé du sport pendant
douze ans avec les deux anciens maires
aujourd'hui je conduis une liste de
rassemblement de gauche écologistes et
citoyennes soutenu par la quasi totalité
des partis de gauche
notre volonté c'est de traiter les
problèmes liés à la crise sanitaire que
ce soit sur le plan économique social et
humain
et puis notre ambition c'est le retour
de l'attractivité sur notre territoire
la transition écologique et puis bien
entendu changer la pratique municipal de
la ville d'héricourt sortir les
pratiques de faim dans le bocal terre
c'est-à-dire teinté de autoritarisme et
d'anti démocratie on y reviendra
alors forcément d'abord c'est une
priorité vous l'avez cité l'attractivité
l'économie comment développer votre
ville dans un contexte local le nord
franche comté qui souffrent
économiquement la filière automobile est
à la peine à belfort on l'a vu encore il
ya quelques semaines general electric
par exemple n'est pas au mieux de sa
forme
comment héricourt peut-elle tirer son
épingle du jeu d'un point de vue
économique fernand burkhalter vous avez
la parole elle a tiré son épingle du jeu
au cours des deux dernières décennies en
créant beaucoup d'emplois notre bassin
d'emploi compte à présent cinq mille
emplois compte 3000 il y a quelques
années seulement 2000 emplois ont été
créés
il en faut encore beaucoup plus 1000
emplois nécessaires supplémentaires
nécessaire pour cette ville nous y
travaillons nous avons de belles
réussites à notre actif beaucoup
d'implantation d'entreprises hermès
qu'est la plus symbolique de 180
salariés x9 dans le domaine médical
creat est également dans le domaine
médical de la création de gel hydro
alcoolique elle nous a bien soutenus
pendant cette crise sanitaire qui a bien
sûr beaucoup affecter la population que
je remercie d'avoir respecté le
confinement est pourtant patrick adam 10
et héricourt c'est une belle endormie
pas du tout c'est pas du tout
l'impression c'est peut-être
l'impression de monsieur adam pas du
tout le sentiment des habitants
d'héricourt mais plus au delà de la
haute saône et loire de la franche-comté
fada réputation de notre ville est forte
elle s'est réveillée il y à bien
longtemps avec les deux maires
précédents dont j'ai été aussi un acteur
à cette époque là avec jean-pierre
michel tout d'abord et ensuite avec jean
michel villaumé et puis je suis dans la
continuité de cette action
1 je travaille avec sérieux et un
certain dynamisme
je dois dire une certaine chance et une
certaine réussite at rica dans monsieur
burkhalter donc quelques chiffres
héricourt possède un taux de chômage de
9,2 pour cent de la population active
à titre de comparaison vesoul sait 7,6 à
taux de pauvreté de 17%
à titre de comparaison sur l'ensemble de
la haute saône c'est 14%
si pour vous cela constitue une réussite
je pense que vous faites preuve d'une
fausseté de jugement manifestes
ensuite vous dites que hermès s'est
développée c'est également un haut point
fort au niveau du développement
économique
moi je suis pour créer des industries de
luxe sur héricourt un véritable médine
héricourt maintenir le tissu industriel
existant mais développer également des
entreprises qui vont faire des produits
qui vont concevoir des produits de haute
valeur qualitative tout en respectant le
facteur humain et avec un respect de
l'environnement mais vous reconnaissez
que l'installation d'hermès à héricourt
c'est une réussite
alors c'est une réussite est à mettre à
l'actif du maire sortant ou pas pas du
tout parce que si vous voulez que moi je
m'interroge sur le pur sang
âge de personnes qui sont d'héricourt et
qui travaillent à cette entreprise
je suis bien placé pour le savoir ma
compagne travail va campagne travail
nous avons déménagé à héricourt parce
que j exerce également la plupart de ces
de ses collègues n'habite pas à
héricourt
donc en fait les personnes qui
travaillent ne font pas vivre la ville
et donc c'est un rat relatifs problème
et quand on voit l'état du centre ville
là il ya vraiment beaucoup à dire
il ya vraiment beaucoup a dit on y
reviendra sur le centre-ville sur le
diagnostic économique gilles lazar je
reprends parce qu'on a parlé d'hermès
hermès c'est le mandat précédent où
j'étais aussi adjointe set où j'étais
aussi à jouer avec monsieur mulcair avec
jean michel villaumé non jours donnera
la parole à fernand buron terre n'est
pas au conseil municipal d'héricourt
monsieur burkhalter laissez moi parler
voilà donc là le développement
économique c'est effectivement très
important et aujourd'hui avec la crise
sanitaire
nous pouvons nous poser des questions
donc faire venir des entreprises
on a parlé d'hermès d'autres sont venus
créat s cetera mais il faut le faire pas
en mettant en concurrence les
territoires ce qui s'est passé en fait
c'est que en fait on fait un déplacement
sur le plan du chômage à héricourt il
n'a pas baissé au contraire il a
augmenté particulièrement dans le
quartier des chenevières donc c'est un
fait c'est un déplacement de
travailleurs qui habite donc belfort
montbéliard et qui viennent travailler
ricour mhz pour le pour le pays
d'héricourt ça n'apporte absolument rien
en terme de consommateurs et donc
quelles sont vos propositions à vous
l'attractivité
où l'avez dit c'est ça la crème itier on
a perdu d'attractivité et les cours a
perdu des habitants
on a gardé le niveau de dix mille cent
dix mille six cents grâce à la fusion
avec t'avais mais en fait ce qu'il faut
c'est des services publics à la hauteur
des services publics de la ville mais
c'est aussi par exemple la fibre on a
perdu cinq ans avec la fibre optique et
on le devait l'avoir en 2020 on va la
voir en 2021
on a un commissariat qui aujourd'hui à
fusionner combelles hier donc la
sécurité reste sur l'économique séoul
est alléchant mais on parlera sévérité
ou des séminaires avoir terminé sur un
point on a une zone économique qui
s'appelle des gi note si vous allez vous
promener là bas ou verrez un terril
donc été plantée au milieu de la zone
parce qu'en fait on veut attirer des
industries des entrepreneurs ayant
finalement ils ne viennent pas cette
opération a coûté un million et demi aux
contribuables pour une peur du vide donc
il faut vraiment être extrêmement
vigilant fernand burkhalter je vous
laisse répondre sur notamment le taux de
chômage la difficulté à attirer de
nouvelles entreprises qu est ce que vous
vous répondez et la fibre effectivement
le taux de chômage reste élevé comme
dans les rues urbaines et comme en haute
saône et c'est regrettable effectivement
souhaiterait de l'emploi pour tous et
notamment avec la crise qui se profile
simplement la richesse d'un territoire
se mesure au nombre d'entreprises et je
crois que nous avons bien travaillé
cette action est reconnue
beaucoup d'entreprises se sont implantés
de nouvelles entreprises heures mais ce
n'est pas une entreprise transférer
c'est une entreprise qui a créé 201 80
ans plan entrant et que ça aussi à créer
beaucoup d'emplois et d'autres
je ne peux pas toutes les citer tant
elles sont nombreuses et sur les
difficultés
d'attraction d'attractivité pour
certaines nouvelles zones non c'est le
contraire effectivement monsieur lazhar
constat critique constamment le
développement de zones d'activités je
vois mal comment on peut installer de
l'activité économique si ce n'est dans
des zones d'activités mermer c'est un
bel exemple d'une implantation centre
ville dans un espace assez restreint qui
a été entièrement requalifier après les
friches industrielles
nous les avons pratiquement tout
requalifier il en reste très très peu
une centaine d'hectares de son géant
qu'elle en 20 ou 30 ans beaucoup
d'hectares ont été qualifiés la ville
s'est transformée c'est l'avis général
c'est l'avis de la tribune en a demandé
la parole on lui donne donc en ce qui me
concerne moi je souhaite concilier la
tradition la modernité héricourt a une
tradition de tissage
on a vu à cause de la crise sanitaire
actuelle que c'était très important
parce qu'on n'a pas pu finalement
bénéficié de masques moi j'avais proposé
dans mon programme d'attirer des
entreprises qui ont ce savoir-faire pour
la création de tissus innovants de
tissus techniques
ça fait partie de notre programme
ensuite moi ce que je constate c'est
alors un certain moment monsieur
burkhalter vous dites que monsieur
lazhar a fait partie de la majorité
monsieur lazhar cherche à se déprendre
ça moi ce que je constate c'est que ce
sont les deux faces de la même pièce
c'est la même idéologie délétère qui
laissent eux stagnent et héricourt vous
faisant j'ai l'impression qu'ils sont
pas d'accord sur grand chose en mai oui
mais sur ce point là moi je les fait se
rejoindre
si vous voulez parce que voilà chacun
cherche à tirer un peu la couverture à
soi
c'est moi qui les fais quand j'étais là
non tu étais tout seul non nous on a une
ambition qui est pour héricourt
héricourt se situe un pôle stratégique à
l'inter mi-chemin entre et vesoul lure
et les rues urbaines
nous ce qu'on souhaite c'est développer
des projets communs avec cette entité
qui est les rues urbaines avec belfort
montbéliard pas à ce qu'ils avaient
l'impression qu'ils rient court et un
peu mis de côté dans ces terres
roumaines par rapport à laax avait bien
un effort montbéliard ah bah bien sûr on
ne peut pas dialoguer avec les maires de
belfort et de montbéliard
puisque nous on a quelqu'un qui est
sectaire et dogmatique et il n'y a très
très peu de points communs
je vais vous donner un exemple dans le
domaine sanitaire il ya dans quelques
nommé
alors juste parce que vous êtes de avoir
employé les mêmes termes sectaires et
dogmatiques est-ce que ça c'est des mots
lancés comme ça est-ce que vous avez des
exemples concrets de ce que vous avancez
et puis on fera répand de fernand
burkhalter a bien écouté il suffit que
vous veniez une fois assister au conseil
municipal
enfin ses crayons s'écriant c'est
monsieur burkhalter ne laisse pas là ne
laisse pas la parole aux personnes
l'opposition quelle que soit quelle
qu'elle soit que ce soit communiste ou
de droite est complètement dénigrer
enfin disons que la parole ne circule
pas l'anglais elle va circuler sur ce
plateau gilles lazar il voit revenir sur
le problème de l'économie et surtout sur
l'étalement urbain
aujourd'hui on a étalé héricourt sur sa
périphérie et on asphyxie en finale des
finales le centre-ville le projet de
monsieur burkhalter c'est de rajouter
encore une couche sur 30 hectares du
côté de luz et de mettre à cinéma en
périphérique alors que le centre-ville
tant grandi depuis difficultés nous ce
qu'on souhaite au contraire c'est
recentrer les activités sur le centre
c'est la raison pour laquelle nous
souhaitons créer un cinéma public en
coeur de ville sur une des nombreuses
friches que nous avons remettre de
l'activité à cinéma à des prix réduits
nous avons en fait monsieur burkhalter
il à la conception des années 70 voilà
on il n'a pas changé par rapport à ça je
m'étale en périphérie jasse fixe il
centre ville et puis tout le monde que
je prendre sa voiture pour faire ses
courses et ils font pas leur quota des
cours ils vont faire leurs courses sur
belfort et montbéliard je vous promets
qu'on reviendra sur les commerces et
notamment les commerces de centre-ville
mais j'aimerais fernand burkhalter que
vous répondiez sûr ils attaquent vos
adversaires votre manière de gérer la
ville autocratique at on entendu pas du
tout je dirige une majorité municipale
soudée unie qui se respectent les uns
les autres
après il y à l'opposition elle joue son
rôle et c'est son droit le plus strict
c'est normal qu'il y ait une opposition
et je crois que je fais beau preuve de
beaucoup d'humilité vis-à-vis de
moi-même mais des avis des autres
je crois que franchement c'est une
critique qui est pas fondé gillard a
levé les yeux au ciel en vous en jaune
racler les habitants ne partage pas
l'avis exprimé par les deux candidats
par exemple créé zone tout récent 1 j'ai
été contacté par la rs il ya une semaine
pour faire une campagne une action de
prévention c'est l' agence régionale de
santé je prêt prévention sur le co vide
auprès du public défavorisé d'héricourt
j'ai accepté c'était simplement
bénévoles j'ai aussi accepté qui est pas
la presse pour paquet problème en
campagne eh bien j'ai reçu un coup de
téléphone vendredi me disant que c'était
annulé parce que monsieur burkhalter n'a
pas voulu l'aider des salles à la rs
parce que c'était moi qui animait cette
action donc oui on en est à ce niveau là
et il est absolument pourrait multiplier
le nombre de valeurs on aimerait bien
voir la voir vous avait annulé
d'interroger la rs la rsg des rapports
confiance avec matisse rang depuis
plusieurs années j'ai monté à bhl
qu'elle est avec la rs le le projet de
territoire santé le contrat dans quel
sens mais sur l'initiative
j'imagine que c'est sur l'initiative qui
a été menée dans tous les départements
non 2 d'un dépistage gratuit dans
certains quartiers ça ne marcherait pas
été d'accord avec cette proposition de
la rs dans la mesure où c'est un
dépistage ciblé sur quatre ou cinq
habitants je voulait l'étendre à 1000
habitants les res m'a dit non il y
aurait eu un seul médecin présent moi je
souhaitais un dépistage massif par un
test naso pharyngé la rs m'a dit c'est
pas possible il ya qu un médecin mais
j'ai dit vous m'avez pas interroger je
suis prêt à associer lancer mon type de
journée deux lequel j'ai assisté ou en
reportage à lons le saunier il y avait
des tests naso pharyngé oui oui
absolument mais cale 4 ou 5 6 je vous
donne mon expérience ils ont ils ont
fait exactement les mêmes tests dans les
quatre départements de franche-comté et
pour ce qui concerne la journée de tests
auxquels j'ai assistés c'était dans un
quartier populaire c'est bon c'est un
saunier n'y eut plus de 80 n'ont pas pu
bénéficier de cette action
à cause de vous voulez compléter puis à
prendre avant si vous voulez tout à fait
sur la gestion de la crise sanitaire
il faut savoir qu'à deux kilomètres
d'héricourt il
médecin généraliste qui est
malheureusement décédé à aucun moment
les médecins n'ont été contactés pour
savoir comment il gérait la crise nous
avons jamais été contacté par la
municipalité
nous avons été contactés par une
association qui s'appelle brevets liés
animations un petit village à côté qui
nous a fourni les masques et les
surblouse pour continuer d'exercer
ensuite le débat entre mes deux
protagonistes est très intéressant parce
que vous financez quand même monsieur
burkhalter
la maison de santé ou exercer monsieur
lazhar un financement
j'ai les preuves ici d'autre part
monsieur lazhar dites-moi malraux la zae
sur deux contres vous l'avez vous avez
continué d'exercer pendant lequel la
maison de santé verrou on va faire le
longer du premier du premier tour au
lendemain sur l'épidémie ducobu idée je
peux vous dire c'est un moment très
difficile de ma carrière et que je
devrai travailler tous les matins la
boule au ventre
et comme vous le savez très bien dit on
a eu aucun aucune aide au début des
récents encore u2 et et les vieux masque
de madame bachelot achats henan et si on
n'avait pas eu le soutien de nombreux
bénévoles pour nous aider avec des
masques notamment je remercie le
crématorium d'héricourt qu'imad devait
masquer s'éloigne à même de la
commission municipale des six prochaines
années et recoure vous finissez en avant
s'il vous plaît donc vous avez continué
à exercer pendant la crise du coc vie de
monsieur lazhar et vous êtes allés
également exercé au centre
d'addictologie où on rencontre des
personnes particulièrement vulnérables
on a été pendant la crise de kobe dont
on n'avait pas on a dévoilé un taux très
bien vous allez pas à le tourner alors
on va la distance je me poserai juste
une question qui n'appellent qu'une
seule réponse
trouvez vous que c'est un lieu adapté
dans le cadre d'une consultation pour
demander à une patiente pourquoi elle
n'est pas allée voter au premier tour je
veux pas le rapport s'est pas l'objet du
débat c'est pas la réponse que
j'attendais ma réponse c'est très bas je
n'ai jamais prononcés ce genre de
phrases très bien je ne vous ferai pas
l'humiliation de surcroît altona pas à
messieurs à distance c'est bon je crois
que vous êtes expliqué
nous sommes allés à la rencontre des
habitants d'héricourt il ya quelques
jours et ils ont dit à maxime bouet rémy
point ce qu'ils attendaient du futur
maire de la commune je vous propose
qu'on les écoute et on revient en
débattre attali quai de la part d'un
maire s'est déjà d'été à l'écouté de la
population
un bon gestionnaire et puis qu'ils
soient assez proches d'eux des habitants
de la ville
même le qualité première de la mer c'est
d'être à l'écouté de ses sujets entre
guillemets donc la population mais les
marseillais qui va écouter
tous les habitants tous les commerçants
et qui va faire des choses pour que sa
commune perdure tant au niveau des
commerçants que des aménagements pour
les
pour les riverains ce que je vois c'est
le commerce qui va pas très très bien
c'est beaucoup de boutiques fermées et
que faire pour améliorer sa jeu
je sais pas trop il les personnages et
les trucs comme ça ne peut pas dépasser
nos super héros
leclerc parce que c'est trop loin ou au
lidl donc on appellera du tout sûr sur
les centres et faire beaucoup de
manifestations en centre-ville pour que
les gens se déplacent à fait et qui
provoque de la dynamique dans le
commerce en plus parce que si vous
arrivez à faire venir les gens il ya du
commerce qui s'installe ce n'est plus
tellement attractif avec tous les
commerces qui sont fermés et tous
c'était mieux avant je pense que c'est
déjà une petite ville qui est déjà pas
mal dynamique et qui a déjà beaucoup de
choses mais on fait toujours améliorée
tout comme tout on peut toujours faire
mieux alors messieurs on a entendu
beaucoup de d'habitants d'héricourt
poser la question du dynamisme
commercial quelles sont vos propositions
en la matière fernand burkhalter ans sur
le commerce je suis très à l'aise je
suis très heureux de constater que la
ville évolue malgré effectivement tous
les centres villes souffrent tous les
commerces de centre-ville
cela dit à l'occasion de la dernière
crise sanitaire et de la fermeture en
quelque sorte administrative des
commerces
j'ai pu mettre en place la ville a mis
en place une aide aux commerçants ils
sont 70 à l'avoir sollicité à hauteur de
750 euros puis une vingtaine m'ont
informé personnellement qu'il ne
souhaitait pas être aidés ils étaient
restés ouverts
c'est l'état bas c'est les boulangeries
les boucheries et s'avère entendez
plusieurs habitants dire le commerce va
mal à héricourt et je crois qu'il faut
redonner le goût aux habitants de
retrouver le commerce de strange centre
ville ces prêts ne s'est pas spécifique
à héricourt que le commerce se fait dans
les grandes surfaces contre lequel mon
concurrent communiste
c'est beaucoup et pencher mais il faut
aussi des surfaces commerciales
d'importance sinon la clientèle par à
l'extérieur est la seule façon de la
retenir
à héricourt c'est effectivement de
développer ses hôtes commercial ou aussi
il ya des commerces indépendants si vous
développez trop les zones commerciales
extérieures c'est le commerce de
centre-ville qui en maintenant le
commerce de centre-ville c'est plutôt
étoffés au cours des dernières années
grâce à une association des commerçants
dynamiques et que nous avons soutenue
elle a retrouvé des couleurs
gilles lazar est ce que l' équilibre
entre les zones commerciales extérieures
et le commerce de centre-ville est
satisfaisant à héricourt selon pas du
tout je vous avais parlé de la vision
des années 70 la première à première
action de monsieur burkhalter
lorsqu'il a pris et que la mairie c'est
de permettre financièrement d'aider
financièrement au super u de quitter le
coeur de ville pour aller s'expatrier à
la sortie des cours
donc là on a mis en difficulté ce que le
centre ville puisque beaucoup de gens
allaient au super u puis après à d
acheter leur pain et aux buralistes c
est donc cette action a coûté quand même
sept cent cinquante mille euros d'argent
public
donc il faut au contraire inverser la
tendance il faut remettre des habitants
dans le centre ville pour pouvoir
consommer dans le centre ville et
aujourd'hui on est on est à notre
situation complètement déséquilibré donc
notre projet c'est de revoir l'urbanisme
bosco coeur il ya une dent et des cours
de nombreuses bâtiments de nombreuses
habitations qui sont dégradées où il ya
des passoires thermiques donc il faut
faire avoir une politique de rénovation
du centre ville pour qu'ils aient à
nouveau des habitants vous l'avez
budgétisé de l'état on à héricourt a
raté héricourt maire d'héricourt a raté
des enveloppes
alors ça ce sera sur 10 ans mais il a
raté un luxe mais il a eu besoin de la
halcyon coeur de ville voient leur a
laissé ça nous d'avoir raté c'est une
action qui est fondamental il faut
absolument que les héricourtois se
réapproprie et compris en lieu de vie
patrick adam iberico mais écoutez je
vais mettre d'accord mais les médias
protagonistes donc moi je suis pour une
vision équilibrée
je pense qu'il faut des grandes surfaces
je les trouve pas trop mal implanté mais
c'est vrai qu'on a un problème qui est
un problème ne nous le cachons pas
complexe des commerces de centre ville
les commerces de centre ville
notre proposition nous nous souhaitons
privilégier les produits locaux les
agriculteurs locaux l'artisanat par le
biais de la création d'un marché couvert
surtout de remettre en place un marché
le samedi ce qui permettrait aux
familles de s'y rendre de déambuler en
ville
ensuite il n'y a pas que les commerces
il ya aussi les activités qu'on peut
trouver en ville nous avons le projet de
créer un bar associatif qui serait en
fait un mix entre une supérette de
proximité un lieu d'échangé de
convivialité intergénérationnelle où les
gens pourraient se retrouver échanger
ensuite il ya un gros prêt méricourt
c'est qu'il faut fluidifier la
circulation en velin pidement mais on
fera alesi alesi parce qu après midi fut
la sienne pas le temps de transport donc
c'est parfait donc avec voilà c'est une
bonne transition
alors moi je te dirai en conclusion de
cet épisode que monsieur burkhalter a
parfaitement réalisé sa transition
écologique quand on voit le nombre de
vitrines où il est dessiné et peint des
petites fleurs très bucolique
ça donne un aspect je dirais très vert à
la ville d'héricourt les commerces
fermaient si je vois la dcri ok gilles
lazar sur les transports la
problématique transport amorcé par votre
voisin mais juste un petit mot sur leur
chauffeur soit centre-ville un tout
petit bois pour dire que nous sommes
pour l'implantation d'une supérette nous
ne croyons pas un marché couvert sur le
centre ville sur les transports nous
sommes sur le front si j'ose dire depuis
cinq ans pour demander d'avoir des
transports d'être connectés comme
n'importe quelle vie d'éleveur urbaine
entre montbéliard et belfort
c'est seulement au bout de cinq ans que
monsieur burkhalter a accepté de
demander aux entreprises de verser la
taxe transport 2 0 qui parce qu'ils
étaient à 0 3 qui est passé à 0 5% c'est
une compétence communautaire c'est tout
à faire quand je parle de ville
attractive
il faut absolument penser aux transports
mais pas seulement 30 donc moi je vois
trop arrosée mais je me sur les
transports je propose alors d'adhérer un
d'adhérer à un syndicat unique de
transport de l'euromed et kiri cours le
pays d'héricourt puis s'y connecter ça a
été fait récemment mais on a perdu cinq
ans on a perdu cinq ans c'est seulement
depuis un an que la ccph bénéficie du
versement transport qui monte à 0,5
donc il faut aller très vite on a perdu
également cinq ans fernand burkhalter
hockey une volonté forte de du maire
d'héricourt de créer un prêt système de
transport local ados c'est une ressource
pérenne qui est la ressource des
entreprises celles bercement mobilité
que monsieur lazhar viens de décrire
avec justesse
cinq cent mille euros cette année nous
disposerons d'un budget de 350 mille
euros pour développer les lignes de
transport en direction de belfort et
montbéliard
j'ai dû convaincre mes collègues maires
qui n'étaient pas tous favorables à la
création de ce versement transport faut
quand même avoir un pouvoir de
conviction
puis je suis heureux de les avoir
convaincus finalement de développer ce
versement transport qui permettra à ya
eu et riva il ya eu aussi la ligne en
direction de l'hôpital il ya déjà
quelques actions très
auzits yves quant aux syndicats à
belfort et montbéliard
cette idée a été écartée tant par
belfort que par montbéliard vous parlez
d'une grosse collectivité organisa parce
que ces personnes un syndicat exigerait
un rassemblement des entités que sont
celles de belfort montbéliard héricourt
et ce rassemblement impliquerait une
fusion effectivement dès versement
transport et belfort n'y est pas prêt
comme montbéliard néanmoins une longe et
sonia j'ai songé à la dispute entre
belfort et montbéliard sur le versement
transport de l'hôpital volonté à la main
alors le chemin nous l'avons trouvé nous
avons trouvé un terrain d'entente avec
belfort et montbéliard
nous devons discuter nous avons créé à
l'automne en décembre 2019 un peu
tardivement à mon goût un syndicat qui
n'a pas de compétence transports qu'àune
compétences de coordination
on va coordonner notre billettique si
possible et coordonner les moyens
d'information
c'est pas du tout un système de
transport intégré un jour viendra
mais il faudra encore dix ou quinze ans
pour arriver à une telle démarche qui
fait passer à dix et il y aller
progressivement si je vais résumer voilà
mais c'est exactement l'inversé que fait
monsieur burkhalter qui travaille à la
hussarde
donc nous avec le domaine du transport
on trouve là la pleine réalisation de ce
que je souhaite mettre en marche
à terme à savoir un triptyque héricourt
belfort montbéliard avec des connexions
vous sûr que les deux autres en ait
envie on en discute on en discute avec
une synergie d'actions notamment au
niveau des bus ensuite le transport ça
se résume pas aux bus
il faut permettre à chacun selon ses
choix de vie d'avoir un mode de
transport qu'ils soient adaptés avec le
meilleur rapport qualité prix et avant
prenant en considération la dimension
écologique
sachez savez-vous que 82% des personnes
sur héricourt utilisent leur véhicule
personnel pour se rendre sur leur lieu
de travail
donc nous ne souhaitons diversifier les
modes de transport en mettant en place
notamment des parcours qui veut des
parkings qui vont favoriser le
covoiturage le développement de liaisons
douces
l'amélioration de ce réseau augmentation
du nombre de bornes de rechargement pour
les véhicules électriques
et puis enfin un remplacement progressif
de la flottille des véhicules de la
municipalité par des véhicule propre
fonctionnant au biogaz
gilles lazar oui le transport ces
transports publics mais ce n'est pas
seulement ça effectivement il ya des
liaisons douces
donc nous sommes favorables à a créé les
dents héricourt des pistes cyclables pas
des petits morceaux ou comme c'est fait
de manière très maladroite dans certains
endroits des vraies pistes cyclables on
puisse rejoindre des territoires des
quartiers d'héricourt les uns aux autres
nous allons d'ailleurs la ville
héricourt et la csph si nous sommes élus
nous s'achèteront des vélos électriques
et puis nous travaillerons à la
connexion en piste cyclable sur
montbéliard et belfort
le vélo c'est pas seulement un moyen de
comment dirais-je pour se faire plaisir
de loisirs c'est et ça deviendra un
moyen de déplacement
et puis bien sûr il ya parts de voir
l'autopartage qu'il faut développer
et puis la marche à pied à dori cours
mais encore faut-il qu'elle soit
sécurisée
ce qui n'est pas le cas aujourd'hui une
ville attractive messieurs c'est aussi
une ville sûre vous aviez évoqué le
problème tout à l'heure la sécurité
alors le commissariat d'héricourt est
désormais sous la tutelle de celui
voisin de montbéliard et ce depuis
janvier 2010 est votre ville fernand
burkhalter at elle bénéficié de cette
fusion ou en at elle pâtit moi je suis
heureux de constater que ceux qui qui
disait que le commissariat disparaîtrait
ont eu tort
le commissariat est maintenu avec des
effectifs pas assez important mais qui
seront étoffées dans les années qui
viennent j'en suis sûr j'en suis
convaincu
un commandant de police on disait il y
aura jamais de commandant de police et
un commandant de police à héricourt et
je travaille régulièrement avec les
autorités locales au sein d'un groupe de
partenariat et de proximité
le gpu qui se réunit tous les quinze
jours pour veiller à la sécurité
quotidienne des habitants il ya des
insurgés il ya quelques difficultés il
ya des points sensibles en matière de
sécurité et nous faisons un travail
intéressant
avec la police d'héricourt songez que
trente fonctionnaires prennent chaque
matin leurs services à héricourt au
commissariat d'héricourt dont les
fonctionnaires de la bac qui prennent
leur service à 12 heures pour le
terminer au cours de la nuit
comme vous le savez et non qu'ils
prennent leur service à 20h et qu'il le
terminer en cours de nuit
c'est des effectifs de police
spécialisés je suis très heureux kerry
cours puissent bénéficier d'un tel
service et je souhaite leur son
développement et bitam patrick alors
vous avez une vision plus nuancée que le
maire sortant je crois en nuance et
c'est un euphémisme
il règne un laxisme certains sur
héricourt ce que monsieur burkhalter
appel incivilités moi j'appelle ça des
lits quand récemment il y à des vols
dans les écoles maternelles et dans les
associations et que monsieur burkhalter
ne souhaite pas porter plainte pour de
manière spontanée pour protéger une
certaine clientèle
nous nous sommes contre sale elle avoue
ne l'accusé de clientélisme de
communautarisme c'est quoi à tout à fait
j'assume j'assume ces accusations
j'assume ces accusations et d'autre part
nous avec comme monsieur lazhar souhaite
mettre en place une police municipale
sans vidéosurveillance
sauf sauf un seul endroit je veux bien
vous nous parliez de vos bonnes actions
et on va réagir après tout à fait donc
pour nous la sécurité c'est pas
simplement un empilement de mesures ces
quatre points la prévention de l'action
de la réparation des préjudices causés
et une réinsertion de personnes ayant
commis ces produits la prévention c'est
des actions de sensibilisation ça passe
par le civisme la citoyenneté et ça
commence dès l'école
la prévention c'est également prévenir
la délinquance routière avec des axes
sur héricourt où les voitures font
facilement plus de 100 kilomètres/heure
et l'action c'est la création d'une
police municipale armée avec des caméras
piétons couple et un développement de la
vidéosurveillance bien de combien de
policiers municipaux et combien budget
parce que ça coûte cher une politique
globale
moi j'ai pris l'exemple sur mon confrère
à luxeuil luxeuil quatrième ville de la
haute-saône quatre policiers municipaux
il faudrait normalement dans l'idéal un
policier municipal pour 1000 habitants
nous nous souhaitons commencer par six
policiers municipaux avec une parité
hommes femmes
d'autre part et et le budget comment et
le budget le
ça sera budgété parce qu'il faut
également créer un centre de récupérer
vision urbain ce sera budgété mais vous
dit pas combien
voilà c'est ça 400000 au filet hasard
alors avec un centre de supervision
urbain et d'autres sénat il faut que la
parole circule gilles lazar c'est assez
insolite un communiste qui veut une
police municipale racontez-nous vous
êtes d'accord avec votre voisin sur le
jour était de ceux qui pensaient que la
sécurité est un droit fondamental des
citoyens d'allonger animé le contrat
local de sécurité
à l'époque où jean jean pierre
chevènement les a créé un jeu ailleurs
monsieur locataires étaient présents ici
j'ai pas très souvent
si j'avais été si j'avais été maire
d'héricourt j'aurais immédiatement
immédiatement porté plainte lorsqu'on a
dérobé pour onze mille euros
d'ordinateurs dans les écoles poiret pas
répondre fernand balade plus là dessus
c'est très clair alors moi je me suis
battu contre la fusion et développe de
du commissariat on va soir d'affaires
les marges sont apaise le vous propose
de venir du monde a perdu les effectifs
contrairement à ce que dit monsieur
blatter ce que je propose c'est qu'à
côté de la police nationale connaît une
police municipale de cinq agents pour
commencer un le coup on a estimé 400000
euros d'investissement pris en charge à
moitié par l'état et le fonctionnement
ses 4000 euros héricourt a largement les
moyens de le faire sans augmenter les
impôts locaux
ce sera une police de proximité qui
rappellera les règles les règles à
chacun d'entre nous chacun d'entre nous
jeunes comme moi je fernand burkhalter
est-ce que vous refusez de porter
plainte quand ya des vols dans les
écoles pour ne pas déplaire à certaines
communautés comme vous accusez votre
monture en plein dans ces deux cas
particulier a été déposée par christophe
godard qui est conseiller municipal
délégué à la sécurité
travail il l'a fait l'essentiel c'est de
le faire il avait conduit une quoi
mettre quinze jours non je lui ai donné
mission des lendemains à monsieur godard
qu'un travail aussi qu'à des activités
salariées qui n'est pas un retraité il
l'a fait après il n'y a pas de délai
pour déposer plainte
la nature de la plainte monsieur bur
calmer ma nature de la plainte
mais je suis certain de ce que
j'apprends quant à la police on à la
police municipale
je crois que mes deux concurrents sont
paszek les chiffres évidemment une
police municipale coûterait entre 500 et
600 mille euros mais ses 30 points de
fiscalité de majoration immédiatement de
la taxe foncière
monsieur lazhar évoque que l'état
participerait c'est fou dans une dépense
supplémentaire à l'état ne financera la
baisse au liban mais aussi pâle non non
c'est le fonctionnement mais malgré tout
les ans 30 % d'impôts en plus locaux
comment fait-on pour toutes les vidéos
leurs bennes 9 mai en ont une l'urne a
pas de police n'a pas de police
nationale à pézenas oui on a gendarmerie
mais bon voilà
moi j'ai la chance la ville d'héricourt
à la chance d'abba une gendarmerie qui
dessert l'est depuis sept ans le milieu
le milieu rural qui desservent le milieu
rural c'est à dire les territoires
ruraux de nourrir la vie de notre
communauté de communes et un poste de
police nationale qui a existé que nous
avons renforcé dès les années 80 le
commissariat a toujours été menacée mais
il est toujours présent dans notre ville
et je souhaite qu'il puisse être grand
portrait de cadres et j'agis en ce sens
maintenant il faut aller porter plainte
à montbéliard quand on a besoin il ya un
nul il ya là on est devant des chronos
vérité il ya quatre jours pleins de
partout il ya quatre agents en fait un
véhicule à héricourt et je salue pour
leur travail efficace mais ils sont
complètement burn out et une en peuvent
plus sont sans arrêt en train de faire
le trajet montbéliard héricourt
c'est pas des conditions de travail pour
désolant police d'ailleurs ils en
souffrent énormément
enfin très rapide mais rapidement avant
de conclure on voit l'évolution de
monsieur lazhar qui après les excuses
social des délinquants je me propose
propose des solutions tronquée nous au
sein de ma liste héricourt vivante c'est
l'association d'une police municipale
armée avec des prérogatives bien défini
couplé à un développement de la
vidéosurveillance et ce n'est que comme
ça qu'on pourrait éviter des situations
telles qu'on les a vus dans les rues
alentour messieurs
on arrive au terme de cette émission je
vais vous demander votre conclusion
pourquoi faut-il voter pour vous
dimanche prochain les airs et courtoise
et les héricourtois vous écoute on
reprend l'ordre du début d'émission
fernand burkhalter votre conclusion s'il
vous plaît en conclusion ce débat
démontre la qualité de notre proposition
de notre projet j'ai développé un
certain nombre avec ma liste une équipe
soudée unie depuis six ans elle se
propose de continuer une action positive
pour héricourt dans le dos dans de
nombreux domaines
l'attractivité du centre-ville
l'écologie nous avons des propositions
encore dans quelques jours le conseil
municipal votera une une aide pour
l'acquisition de vélos électriques et de
vélo vtc en faveur d héricourt doigt une
aide de 100 euros 70 500 heureux c'est
très important
l écologie nous l'avons démontré est une
de nos préoccupations aujourd'hui
majeurs merci monsieur burkhalter
patrick adam votre conclusion si vous je
dirais à tous ceux qui pensent qu eje
cour peut devenir une ville d'avenir où
chacun quel qu'il soit pourra trouver à
se réaliser qu'ils souhaitent des
interactions de qualité avec les autres
villes de l'est rurbaine la réalisation
de projets en commun qui aspire un
développement économique et urbain
harmonieux prenant en considération le
facteur humain et l'environnement
à tous ceux qui ont eu le sentiment
d'avoir été délaissée par la droite qui
ont été trahis par la gauche ou qui de
manière plus globale ne croient plus aux
politiques à tout cela je dis oser le
changement parce que le monde d'après ne
se construira pas avec les hommes
d'avant le 28 juin votez héricourt
vivante
merci monsieur adam monsieur lazhar
votre conclusion s'il vous plaît nous
voulons imprimer un souffle nouveau en
matière de développement économique
l'attractivité et de soutien aux
associations culturelles et sportives
nous engagerons avec force dans la
transition écologique qui s'impose à
nous pour protéger nos habitants
notamment les plus âgés du changement
climatique
monsieur burqa terres rares et précis le
champ des possibles fossilisés le débat
démocratique
cela doit cesser nous sommes convaincus
qu'au soir de sommes convaincus que le
dimanche prochain un grand rassemblement
se fera autour de l'autre a dit ce que
je conduis et je devrais dire pour
terminer aux abstentionnistes
n'ayez pas peur aller voter merci
monsieur lazhar merci à tous les trois
d'avoir participé à ce débat dimanche on
vote donc deuxième tour des élections
municipales nos programmes nos débats
continue demain belfort qu une longue et
besançon jeudi profitez bien de votre
soirée dans un instant l'information en
région d'el soirée sur france 3
[Musique]